[MUSIC PLAYING]
Neural networks in 10 seconds.
Oh, let me think about this one.
So I think neural
networks, what comes
to mind when I hear that is
this idea of trying to teach
a computer to learn
something from data
rather than being directly
instructed by a human.
Talking to another person it's
a lot easier to teach a person
how to identify a dog by
showing them different dogs
and they can sort
get the gist of it
and figure it out,
then by giving them
a set of rules and
things to look.
For like it has ears
and has this and that,
because so many other
things have that as well.
That was way longer than
10 seconds but it's short.
Think about pattern recognition,
like building algorithms
that can do efficient pattern
recognition but you're actually
trying to get these pattern
recognition algorithms to do
automated tasks.
Layers of statistical processes
where you have an input
and based off of these
things that you have
in the middle, some outcome.
[LAUGHTER]
I feel like that was really bad.
I can redo that one later maybe.
How hard it is to separate
pluses from minus in a graph
all depends on
kind of how they're
distributed in that picture.
When your networks
are all about is
how do you reshape the
picture so that drawing, oh
that's a terrible explanation.
That's so hard.
OK.
Learning to compose simple
functions over and over again
to solve really hard problems.
Artificial neural networks
are digital structures
that mimic the human neural
networks to compute tasks.
Neural nets are basically
function approximators
that are built on
sort of intuition
that we have about
how the brain works.
Neural networks is basically
a matrix multiplication
and non-linearity plus
autograd, auto differentiation.
It allows you to
approximate any functions
you want theoretically, but
that doesn't happen because they
have intrinsic biases.
A, big, big, big matrices.
Lots of matrix multiplication.
Nonlinear functions
make everything work.
Neural networks are really
big, complicated machines
with lots and lots
of knobs and dials.
And learning a neural network
is just tuning these knobs
and dials correctly.
And how do you tune
these knobs and dials?
With the derivative,
with gradient descent.
In order to minimize
some loss you
need to figure out the way to
tune these knobs and dials.
Do you want to go back to
the neural networks one?
Just use someone else's answer.
[MUSIC PLAYING]